foreign
Noah's in Sacramento hi Noah how can we
help
hey Dave I've got a question I've got a
considerable amount of student debt in a
Parent PLUS Loan and I'm trying to
figure out how to make affordable
payments on a loan that's in my parents
name what feels it feels a little bit
unaffordable at the moment
What's the total amount of debt
it is 175.
and good Lord are you a doctor or a
lawyer
neither one what did you get your degree
in
uh Christian Ministries I'm a pastor for
175 000 dollars
yeah
okay
bad choice and um God that was not you
may be called to the ministry you
weren't called to this mess
um
the uh what is your what is your
household income
uh sixty thousand oh Sean
I'm so sorry
so Mom and Dad took out these loans The
Parent Plus Loans
correct and they can't pay them
they they I mean they can take part our
agreement was that we would split at
half before I went to school that was
the that was the agreement
are they struggling to pay them right
now
they've been in deferment and and
forbearance and whatnot so nobody's made
any payments on them at this point and
I'm in my parents household income is
considerably more uh than ours we're
just trying to figure out uh again I I
don't know how a lot of this works but
I've been told by the the lender and
what not that we can't like consolidate
them into my name or anything like that
and so we're just trying to figure out
what to do they're going to be in their
name you're just going to assist in the
payment of it and so they're going to
give you like their password and the
website and you're going to jump on
there and pay payments on their loan
it's their loan it's going to be their
loan until it's over
but you're just you're you're your moral
agreement your handshake is that you're
picking up half of it
and so um what what does your wife make
uh she's not working at the moment we
have a young daughter and she's pregnant
literally nine days past her due date
today oh wow that's her second kid good
congratulations uh so I I assume she's
planning on going back to work though
uh yeah when when we don't have very
young children yes that's the plan
okay
okay all right well I mean you're just
gonna be paying payments on this no one
Noah um and the math is telling me that
this is a highly stressful situation
so uh it is I I
think you're going to be running you're
going to be what we call a bifocational
pastor
uh you're gonna be running side hustles
of some kind there's nothing wrong with
that it doesn't if it doesn't
most pastors statistically one number I
saw was 80 percent of them are by
vocational in America right now and
there's no shame in that it's not it
doesn't diminish your call it doesn't do
any of that but it's not unusual at all
for a young Pastor to be bi-vocational
and you're going to have to have some
more money it's a mathematical problem
you've got